he's a 10
but he hates your best friend
i hate her too sometimes
selena gomez and her bestie francia
raisa share their dating deal breakers
hopping on the latest tick tock trend
the heat is a 10 challenge he's a 10
but his breath stinks
and i can't fix that
you
try the pals turn to asking each other
what other qualities signal a red flag
when dating there you go bye
and there are a few scenarios that are a
hard no for the duo
he's a 10
but doesn't like dogs
no i'm out
he's a 10 but he hates everything that
you've ever been in feels oh it would be
awful yeah
bye boy sorry i need the love
he's a 10 but he says you can never have
a glass of wine again okay now you're
just challenging my emotions and that's
really
we get it a girl's gotta have her wine
to unwind
all about balance
it's nice to see selena and francia
reunite since we know their friendship
runs deep my personal life and my family
and my friends i'm just i'm in a really
happy place it's been good they met
years ago and grew close and of course
francie approved her selflessness in
2017 when she donated her kidney to
selena who struggles with lupus and
ultimately saved the singer's life i
called her assistant and i said give me
the information i want to do this how
are you feeling in that moment my
kitties were just done the thought of
asking somebody to do that
was really difficult for me it is
incredibly difficult to find a match the
fact that she was a match
i mean that's unbelievable and a few
years later francia told et how proud
she is to be a donor i'm healthier than
ever before and i just recently started
talking about being a living kidney
donor other donors have been texting me
other
recipients waiting have been texting me
and i didn't realize for myself how
important it was to speak to other
donors
talk about inspiring we love to see
these two besties living their best
lives which includes celebrating
milestone birthdays
[Music]
yeah that's sale dancing like nobody's
watching at her big 30th birthday bash
over the weekend francia attended with
her two sisters and sells
dirty 30 look like the party to be at
for now we love watching the ladies
living life to the fullest and when the
time comes to settle down we have a
feeling they'll hold each other
accountable on those dating do's and
don'ts
he's a 10.
but he likes his toes sucked
[Music]
[Music]
you